doesn't make much sense to me well I'll
do it alright alright then oh wait I
wasn't ready
what did you do did you take my picture
was that the official weigh-in I don't
know hey Boris hey what are you doing
whoa uh hang on I need to do some quick
can you stop staring at me like a
freaking weirdo my god you got beautiful
eyes you got ugly everything else but
beautiful eyes
I got it fit oh jeez sorry about that
Boris boink oh my god you're angry Oh
give me big kiss
oh you're such a beautiful chubby
cheeked you little [ __ ] oh look at you
bow oh boy boo boo boo oh you got iron
crest everything else about you is
wicked [ __ ] my trainer more like my
failure my failed creation my failed son
but you got a nice chest though Bowie
Bowie
oh and big boy big boy who's Boris the
big boy oh um me and me me me did I just
get turned around oh I got turned around
oh I'm sorry I'm an idiot okay never
mind so you're over there I thought you
were over there for some [ __ ] reason
I don't know why oh hey how's it going
okay so you're over there
you're right there alright so an enemy
on guard will block your swings oh she's
my hands
they call me clasp hands markiplier oh
no okay oh I just told you I was glass
hands markiplier why have you done this
all right pulling your fists farther
back will do more damage well look at
this I'm gonna do the sonic wind up on
you [ __ ] I'm boskie I didn't seem like
let me just wind it up
oh [ __ ] Boris Boris
oh oh it's Ryan okay Boris come on
that's some weird Lucha Libre headgear
you got going on there oh whoa whoa
Boris Boris come on let's talk about
this I don't know where the edge of the
map is what's these boards come on aah
whoa back up a little bit huh aah
I'm just giving you a bit whoa geez I
saw something I didn't want to see Boris
a dodgy [ __ ] oh oh oh [ __ ] what good
huh you can't hit me okay we can't see
Oh [ __ ] Oh what you gonna do glass and
wicked huh what you gonna do huh whoa
okay what you gonna do what you gonna do
huh BAM
Oh No yeah [ __ ] you don't get up don't
don't hey hey hey come on I don't fight
fair yeah oh you're out for good Boris
don't even try to get back up oh oh hey
hey no hard feelings eh Boris uh we're
cool ugly Joe miss Sato I'll take him oh
come on I got my shower oh hey oh man
you really are ugly oh boy you've got no
ABS nice grundle
I like this let me fix your bow hand let
me get this I got it all right oh you
like that yeah how about a little bit on
the tip of your giant nose Oh
smells like a butterfly just like a bean
my face well everything's getting dark
huh boys oh [ __ ] huh oh
what Sidewinder I throw a wicked
haymaker no one tell master mouth
watching on me oh look at me go oh don't
get up
it's okay don't don't get up for me huh
now yet
thank you wow I only dodge to the right
one-two combo whoa
one-two combo whoa you're ugly ugly [ __ ]
bro ow ow black boy boy boy boy get some
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm knocked my headphones
out [ __ ] yeah
pause it pause what timeout all right
back in it Oh
huh huh oh good oh yeah you think I had
that had you my late don't knock him out
god damn it I did it again [ __ ] okay
this right one I don't know why oh I'm
good thanks buddy
okay here we go ugly I don't even
remember what your name is
whoa whoa oh oh oh oh
glass hand marklar wins again admittedly
my first win was only against my trainer
but you get you get OH
oh geez hi Boris are you all right
ugly Joe wait where's some more well
there's no more what what I beat him I
beat him fair and square what do I gotta
beat him again probably
nice good combo me thanks me I'm really
making my family proud
look my getting my brain beat out of me
whoop wham wham wham wham wham your face
caved in buddy boy
come on ma come on [ __ ] ah there we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah well no don't get up
don't get up don't you Jesus huh
whoa my lights but you got yours [ __ ]
I'm the winner
Wow oh [ __ ] sorry I hate you
oh sorry
okay oh boy well it doesn't look like
there's any more opponents right now
whoa [ __ ] where how do I get over there
okay so it doesn't look like there's any
more opponents right now but I sure beat
the [ __ ] out of that guy twice so that's
all for thrilling hi a little bread a
very sweaty I'll bite throw up yeah
what do you think of that maybe they're
gonna add more fighters later but this
is what I imagined when I thought there
was gonna be a boxing game in the vibe
pretty cool right so let me know what
you thought in the comments down below
all right still catch my breath hey
thanks again everybody for watching if
you want to see more cool 5 games I've
done to pass it'll be a link in the
description thanks again for watching
again and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye
oh hi
oops ha